we begin with this the US government is
ramping up its response to the
coronavirus President Trump last night
signed into law a sweeping hundred
billion dollar relief bill it guarantees
paid sick leave expands unemployment
benefits and makes coronavirus testing
free and the more we test the more
infections we find infections in the US
have now topped ninety four hundred and
at least a hundred and fifty two people
have died let's get to our lead national
correspondent David Begg know who is
self qty self quarantine eing in his New
York apartment David good morning what
do you got Tony good morning you know we
hear so much about the numbers but we've
been trying to focus on the stories
behind those numbers I want to tell you
about the Fusco's a close-knit family
from central New Jersey weekend family
dinners are reportedly a tradition in
their household they are regulars at
Sunday Mass but the virus has tragically
affected them at least six six of them
have tested positive for kovat 19 and
three of them have already died
including 73 year-old grace Fusco who
was a mother to 11 and a grandmother to
27 at least three of the Fusco's are
still in critical condition this morning
now on the other hand let me tell you
about some good news out of one of the
hardest hit areas in New York a New
Rochelle lawyer who was one of the first
to be diagnosed with the virus in New
York State is now on the road to what is
apparently a full recovery
Laurens car boozes wife tells CBS this
morning that he is awake and alert and
after reportedly being in a medically
induced coma for more than a week his
first words to her after he was taken
off the ventilator were I love you so
much
that's beautiful David I'm so glad that
you ended on that note we've been
following that story and you hear
medically induced coma you think this
could go a couple of ways I'm so glad
that it's turned out the way it has it's
very good news
thank you David Beck now I thought you
would be use not to show that yeah we're
very happy to hear that